For centuries it was well known that
the health of one soul required people to spend periods
away from the city. Somewhere isolated, peaceful
and spiritual.
It is this impasse that explains why for centuries
all the major religions built monasteries -
beautiful pieces of architecture in quiet places.
"The school of life" is a global organization
commited to psychological health and well-being.
Our headquarters are in some of the world major urban centers -
London, Paris, Amsterdam, Melbourne,
Seoul, Istanbul, but we have always longed to be able
to help our audiences from around the world
find some other peace of mind
once offered by monasteries. It was with this in mind
that "The school of life" got interested in
the work of the great British architect - John Pawson,
who has designed several monasteries, churches
and places of contemplation.
The result of our collaboration is now open -
a beautiful secular monastic building
in the middle of a deserted rugged valley in central Wales.
The school of life´s secular monastery,
that we call simply "The life house".
The Life House has three large bedrooms,
each dedicated to one of the great ways that humans has over the centuries
salt serenity.
The literature room is entirely oriented to reading
and has a carefully curated library, decked out
with books we have choosen.
Next comes the music room,
equipped with a state-of-the-art music equipment and a selection of some of the best
therapeutic, relaxing music of the world.
Finally, there is the bathing room, a bedroom with a large
sunken beth in it, with vistas on the Welsh countryside
in all directions.
The house includes a contemplation chamber,
buried deep in the hillside, where you can sit alone and listen to water trickling
into a fountain and collect yout thoughts and calm anxieties.
The School of Life has always been dedicated to mental well-being.
With the launch of our "Life House"
we have taken the best lessons from the monastic traditons of old
and updated them for the modern age.
Do come and stay!